as I mentioned your co-star in this
movie is Charlie Day it's the two of you
co-starring well hold on I'm actually
just starting moving I mean he's he's
the co-star you know I'm saying he's a
supporting act I'm gonna start you know
if it was it was bananas
I'd be the first banana he'd be the
second than that you know I mean that's
what I'm saying if it was cheese I'd be
the Big Cheese he'd be the little cheat
okay yeah you know how fair
[Applause]
you're gonna find the star of this fight
what are you doing with you to start
what you're doing up there while I'm up
here promoting it if you discard I don't
like being close to Conan he gets too
handsy I don't get handsy what are you
talking about get your ass down here I
should come down
[Applause]
the I'm gonna pull some [ __ ] like this
man you know this is my movie I'm a
stylist movie Conan and who had the
bigger trailer on set
you got a trailer don't nobody go to
Charlie Day movies man yeah I mean it's
like come on man your name is you're not
Morris day you're Charlie day you're ice
cube what kind of name is ice cube is
that supposed to be that's the scariest
name you can think of was ice cube like
is anyone scared of an ice cube
you're gonna melt me on these you should
even be in a movie with me man are you
even tall enough to go to the movies
what is that there's no height
requirement to go to a movie still you
want to make that joke that Kevin Hart
you know dude I'll fight you I'll fight
you right now
[Applause]
little sneaky mother I will say play
your lip shut and shut that dirty mouth
I will poke you for all skill I'm out of
here
security to me I'm out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh sneaky little that is not my security
guy
IceCube everybody nicely
[Applause]
you